SHILLUE!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
GREG: SO I THINK WE FOUND THE
ONE THING WORSE THAN FAKE
OUTRAGE, FAKE RIGHTEOUSNESS.
>> WE ARE HERE TODAY TO CROSS A
VERY IMPORTANT THRESHOLD IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> WE ARE ON THE PRECIPICE OF A
GREAT HISTORIC MOMENT DEALING
WITH PROTECTING THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> THIS HISTORIC MOMENT --
>> THE GRAVITY AND THE HISTORIC
NATURE OF THIS MOMENT --
>> THE SOLEMNITY, THE GRAVITY OF
THE MOMENT IN OUR HISTORY HITS
YOU SQUARE IN THE BACK.
GREG: LIKE A POMPOUS TOURETTE'S.
THRESHOLDS, PRECIPICE OF
GRAVITY.
JACKASSES.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY PUT A WEDDING DRESS ON A
SACK OF DOG TURDS AND ROLLED IT
DOWN THE AISLE.
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT ABOUT ALL THAT WALKING,
HUH?
YEAH, LET'S LOOK AT THEM WALK.
[LAUGHTER]
OOH, THESE IDIOTS CAN WALK IN A
STRAIGHT LINE WITHOUT TRIPPING
OVER THEIR OWN EGOS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A MEDIA THIS
EXCITED, CELEBRATING THE FACT
THAT THESE HALF WITS CAN WADDLE
TOWARDS AN OPEN SPACE.
WE LEARN THIS WHEN WE'RE 4.
HERE THEY ARE WALKING.
AND HERE THEY ARE WALKING SOME
MORE.
[LAUGHTER]
OH, AND DID YOU SEE THEM WALKING
HERE?
OOH, AND, OH, LOOK AT THIS WALK.
[LAUGHTER]
OH, THAT'S A NICE WALK.
AND SOME MORE WALKING.
THAT'S WALKING.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THIS WALKING, THERE YOU GO.
UH-HUH.
AND YET THE MEDIA LAUGHED IT
OFF.
GOTTA HAND IT TO THE DEMS, THEY
PUT THE MONEY IN THE JUKEBOX AND
HOW THE PRESS DANCES.
>> JUST THE CEREMONY OF IT,
WALKING OVER, DELIVERING THE
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT --
>> YOU'LL SEE THEIR SIGNING PENS
THERE --
>> THE PRESENTATION AND THE POMP
AND ALL THAT CONTRIBUTES TO THAT
GRAVITY --
>> YOU SEE THE POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE AND THE FORMALITY
AND THE SERIOUSNESS.
>> THE BUILDING FILLED WITH
STATUES.
THERE'S A SACRAMENTAL QUALITY TO
THIS, THERE'S A RITUAL.
>> WE'RE NOW SEEING THE MANAGERS
WALKING BACK FROM THE SENATE
THROUGH THE ROTUNDA.
>> I THINK PELOSI'S A REAL
BELIEVER IN THIS RITUAL.
I THINK SHE'S VERY REVERENTIAL.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: THANKSES, CHRIS, BUT YOU
ALSO THINK THE BLOW DRYER AT THE
GYM ISN'T JUST FOR YOUR HAIR.
[LAUGHTER]
CEREMONY, STATUES, SACK REMS,
RITUAL, THEY'RE AS GIDDY AS BILL
CLINTON AT A SLUMBER PARTY, AND
THEY CAN'T EVEN HIDE IT.
THAT'S THE REAL POINT.
THE BREATHLESSNESS REVEALS THEIR
BUY WITH WHEREAS.
SO IS THIS REALLY HISTORIC?
IT'S ONLY THE THIRD TIME
SOMEONE'S BEEN IMPEACHED, BUT
THAT'S IRRELEVANT IF THE PROCESS
IS ABUSED.
ANYONE CAN DO AN IMPEACHMENT IF
YOU HAVE CONTROL OF THE HOUSE,
AND SINCE THE DEMS NOW BROKE THE
SEAL, YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A LOT
MORE OF IT.
IT'S NOW NO LONGER ANYTHING
SPECIAL.
NOW IMPEACHMENT IS GOING TO BE
AS REGULAR AS ME ON METAMUCIL.
[LAUGHTER]
AM I RIGHT, ADAM?
>> AND NOW, ADAM SCHIFF WATCHES
A TRUMP RALLY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO --
WELL, I WON'T BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
THIS WEEK.
BUT, YOU KNOW, HE'S PROBABLY
THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
GOT 'EM LINED UP, ADAM, YOU
LITTLE PENCIL NECK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I MAY HAVE A PENCIL NECK, BUT
LOOK AT THIS FACE.
>> THE WASHINGTON DEMOCRATS ARE
WASTING AMERICA'S TIME WITH
DEMENTED HOAXES AND CRAZY WITCH
HUNTS.
>> PROVE IT.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: SO THERE ARE SEVEN
IMPEACHMENT MANAGERS.
TAKE A LOOK AT 'EM.
HAVE YOU SEEN A SADDER
COLLECTION OF BAFFOONS?
THEY LOOK LIKE REJECTS FROM
PEOPLE'S COURT.
[LAUGHTER]
NOW REMEMBER, WHEN YOU WATCH
THESE LEMMINGS, YOU'RE FOOTING
THE BILL.
SO THEY'RE CRAPPING ON US WHILE
WE SIGN THEIR CHECKS.
GOTTA REMEMBER THIS SO WHEN IT'S
OVER, THERE'S PAYBACK.
WE'VE GOT THE VOTE THEM OUT AND
NEVER PAY THEM AN OUNCE OF
RESPECT EVER AGAIN.
AND DON'T FORGET, THIS IS ALL
DUE TO THE FACT THEY CAN'T BEAT
TRUMP.
LIKE ALL THEIR BIG DREAMS AFTER
THE BUILDUP, IT ALWAYS
COLLAPSES.
COLLUSION, OBSTRUCTION,
KAVANAUGH, COVINGTON, AVENATTI.
THE BIG STRATEGY ALWAYS DEFLATES
IN THEIR ARMS LIKE A PUNCTURED
BLOW-UP DOLL.
[LAUGHTER]
AM I RIGHT, ADAM?
>> AND NOW, ADAM SCHIFF USES A
VENDING MACHINE FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I FOUND YOU, SNACKS, BUT HOW
TO ACCESS THEM.
BILL, WE MUST FIND BILL.
SUCH A SMALL SPACE.
ARE YOU BILL?
NO, YOU'RE TOO BIG.
>> BIG?
>> TO FIT IN THE MACHINE.
DON'T TWIST MY WORDS.
>> I'M GOING TO COME BACK LATER.
>> TELL BILL I'M LOOKING FOR
HIM.
I CAN WAIT.
I CAN WAIT FOR YOU, BILL.
[LAUGHTER]
AH, BILL.
GREG: TRUMP WROTE THE LAW
SIGNING TRADE DEALS, KILLING
TERRORISTS AND CHAPERONING A
RECORD STOCK MARKET.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF IMPEACHMENT IS
A VITAMIN THAT MAKES HIM FOR
EFFECTIVE.
PLUS SO MANY OTHER CONCERNS.
I MEAN, HOW ABOUT THE SHOWER?
>> HOW ABOUT THE SHOWER?
[LAUGHTER]
I HAVE THIS BEAUTIFUL HEAD OF
HAIR, AND YOU GO INTO THE
SHOWER, RIGHT?
YOU TURN ON THE WATER, DRIP,
DRIP, DRIP.
>> BUT WHAT ABOUT THE LIGHTBULB?
>> I BROUGHT BACK THE OLD
LIGHTBULB.
BETTER LIGHT FOR MUCH LESS
MONEY, IF YOU WANT IT.
SOMEBODY SAID, SIR, DON'T
MENTION THE LIGHTBULB.
YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD TO -- SO THE
NEW LIGHTBULB COSTS YOU FIVE
TIMES AS MUCH, AND IT MAKES YOU
LOOK ORANGE.
[LAUGHTER]
AND I WAS MORE INTERESTED IN THE
ORANGE.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: BUT WAIT, WHAT ABOUT THE
REFRIGERATORS?
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT
REFRIGERATORS, PROBABLY NOT IN
THE STATE OF THE UNION.
I'LL LEAVE IT OUT BECAUSE I WANT
TO GET PRAISE.
YOU CANNOT MAKE A BRILLIANT
SPEECH WHERE THEY SAY THAT WAS
SUCH AN INCREDIBLE, ELEGANT
SPEECH IF I'M TALKING ABOUT
DISHWASHERS, IS SINKS, TOILETS,
LIGHTBULBS.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
BUT SINKS, TOILETS AND SHOWERS,
YOU DON'T GET ANY WATER.
GREG: HE CAN'T, HE CANNOT HELP
HIMSELF!
[LAUGHTER]
I HOPE AT LEAST HE'S IMPROVING
NEW DISHWASHERS.
>> I'M ALSO APPROVING NEW
DISHWASHERS THAT GIVE YOU MORE
WATER SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY WASH
AND RINSE YOUR DISHES WITHOUT
HAVING TO DO IT TEN TIMES.
FOUR, FIVE, SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT,
NINE, TEN.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: HE SPEAKS FOR ALL OF US.
[LAUGHTER]
ANYONE HAVE A NEW DISHWASHER?
>> ANYBODY HAVE A NEW
DISHWASHER?
I'M SORRY FOR THAT.
T WORTHLESS.
IT'S WORTHLESS.
SO LITTLE WATER.
IS SO WHAT HAPPENS?
YOU END UP USING IT TEN TIMES,
AND THE PLATES -- THEN YOU TAKE
THEM OUT AND DO THEM THE
OLD-FASHIONED WAY.
GREG: I WONDER IF HE'S DONE WITH
THE DISHWASHER?
>> SO DISHWASHERS NOW ARE GOING
TO HAVE JUST AS MUCH AS YOU'VE
EVER HAD, AND YOU'RE GOING TO
USE NOW ONE SHOT.
YOUR DISHES ARE GOING TO BE
BEAUTIFUL.
I'M SORRY THAT YOU JUST BOUGHT
ONE OF THOSE BRAND NEW PIECES OF
GARBAGE.
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: ALL RIGHT.
LET'S FACE IT, WE DON'T DESERVE
HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
BECAUSE HERE HE IS TRYING TO
SOLVE BIG AND LITTLE PROBLEMS
AROUND THE WORLD FROM TRADE WITH
CHINA TO IRAN, TO YOUR CRAPPY
APPLIANCES.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT HE'S ONLY GOT ONE QUESTION
IN MIND, HOW DO I MAKE IT
BETTER?
HIS OPPONENTS QUESTION HOW CAN
WE STOP HIM.
THE ANSWER IS THEY CAN'T.
IN FACT, THE MORE YOU TRY TO
STOP HIM, FOR SOME BIZARRE
REASON, THE BETTER HE DOES.
RIGHT, ADAM?
[LAUGHTER]
>> AND NOW, ADAM SCHIFF GOES ON
A SKI TRIP.
>> I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
SKI TRIP.
>> DUDE, I CANNOT WAIT TO HIT
THE SLOPES.
>> I HEARD IT'S SUPPOSED TO SNOW
ALL WEEKEND.
>> OH, MY GOD, LET'S GET IT.
>> READY FOR SOME SUN IN THE
FUN, FELLAS?
>> ADAM, WHERE IS YOUR SKI GEAR?
>> AREN'T YOU FREEZING?
IT'S LIKE 20 DEGREES.
>> THE ONLY ONE I CARE ABOUT IS
THIS ONE, FROM STANFORD.
>> WHERE DID YOU GET THAT ONE?
>> STANFORD.
>>, NO WHERE DID IT COME FROM?